what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder Disney and Marvel
have fired yet another Marvel executive
today further proving that Disney and
Marvel Studios truly are shaking things
up however today was a pretty big one
they fired the person who was actually
responsible for Disney owning Marvel
Studios however he was also responsible
for a lot of contention within Disney
and he was the person who tried to get
Kevin feige fired yes they fired Isaac
Ike pearlmutter the chairman of Marvel
entertainment and quite possibly the
most controversial executive that Marvel
had now the reports today that come with
this firing of Ike Pearl mutter truly do
tell us that we are in for a good
old-fashioned shake-up with the MCU but
as we've been talking about over the
past couple of months this is believed
to be a good thing however this will
result in some delays we've already kind
of started to see them but overall this
is going to be a very good thing for
Marvel Studios and the MCU and of course
I'll break it all down so some people
might actually hate but also love Ike
Pearl Mudder because he is the reason
that Disney now owns Marvel Studios and
the characters that come with Marvel but
he is also the reason that Disney does
not own Spider-Man and didn't own any of
the X-Men until recently Ike prometer
gained control of Marvel in the late
1990s and what he did at that time was
expand its merchandising business and he
licensed properties like the X-Men and
Spider-Man to different movie studios so
right now he is currently why Spider-Man
is not owned by Disney now he did not
know what Marvel Studios was going to
turn into back then he didn't know
anything about the MCU of course he was
just trying to make Marvel work until
eventually he sold Marvel to Disney in
2009 now since he sold Marvel to Disney
in 2009 his role and his involvement
with Marvel and Marvel Studios has
greatly diminished over time and by the
end of his career which was Monday March
27th his role with Marvel Studios was
pretty much nothing he was really over
Marvel entertainment so his job by the
end was pretty much just publishing the
comics which is a big deal of course but
as far as being involved with movies or
shows he really wasn't anymore and the
reason for that is he tried to get Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
the person who started the Marvel
Cinematic Universe fired he tried to get
Kevin feige fired luckily at that time
like I said he sold Marvel to Disney in
2009 and this was past that point so Bob
Iger was in charge and Bob Iger stepped
in and said no you're not firing Kevin
feige and that's not the only real
controversial thing that he's kind of
done at Disney he was very very against
diversity in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he consistently said that these
diverse characters and these smaller
characters weren't going to work in the
MCU and they wouldn't sell as much
merchandise in fact the reason that he
lost oversight site of movies for Marvel
Studios in 2015 was because of his Feud
with Kevin feige Ike pearlmutter and
Kevin feige were arguing over the costs
of the first Doctor Strange film they
didn't see eye to eye and pearl mutter
wanted to fire Kevin feige but like I
said Bob Iger stepped in and overruled
him thank you Mr Iger and it is good to
have you back but when he did have some
say over the Marvel movies one of the
biggest influences that he had was in
2013 with Iron Man 3. Kevin feige had
Rebecca Hall's Maya Hanson set up to be
the villain of Iron Man 3 however Ike
prometer put his foot down and he
changed the villain to guy Pierce's
Aldrich Killian and the reason that he
made that change was because he thought
that a male villain would do better than
a female villain wouldn't sell as much
merchandise so that's why we got
aldrich's Killian as the villain of Iron
Man 3 because of Ike Pearl Mudder
however like I mentioned his dispute
with Kevin feige in 2015 would cost him
control over all and any of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Marvel Studios movies
that they produced from then on out it
was pretty much Kevin feige's cult and
it's really interesting that he fought
him over all this because at this point
in time we were already well into the
MCU we already had our first Avengers
film which was a huge and massive
success so it's really interesting that
he would still fight with Kevin feige
after all of the success that Marvel
Studios had already had and actually Ike
Perlmutter was almost responsible for
something truly tragic now he tried to
get Kevin foggy fired by Bob Iger
stepped in and said no however Kevin
feige at one point was pretty distraught
with Marvel Studios and how everything
was going Kevin buggy wanted diverse
characters in the MCU but Ike promoter
was fighting against him he had a lot of
opposition towards this and this almost
caused Kevin feige to take a position at
DC this could have drastically changed
the entire superhero world as we know it
who know shows what would have happened
if Kevin feige left the Marvel Cinematic
Universe if he left Marvel Studios we
are not sure what would have happened to
Marvel Studios and if he went over to DC
well perhaps it could have been a little
bit better in fact I'm sure it would
have been I'm sure Kevin foggy would
have went over to DC and established a
true cinematic connected Universe this
really could have changed everything
however Ike prometer would eventually
lose oversight with anything relating to
movies or shows in 2019 he lost
oversight of Marvel television which at
the time consisted of the Marvel Netflix
shows and eventually of course they all
ended and Disney plus became a thing and
Kevin feige is now in charge of all of
them and he's bringing them over to the
MCU he's already brought back Daredevil
he's bringing back the Punisher he's got
Kingpin back already and rumor is
Jessica Jones is going to join them as
well in the Daredevil series now the New
York Times have reported that he was
fired on Monday they reached out to
Disney and Disney confirmed this however
they got no comment from Ike chromutter
this comes from Bob tiger the CEO of
Disney right now his attempt to cut cost
where they are firing over 7 000
employees all across Disney that's about
four percent of its Global total and
it's 5.5 billion dollars in cuts and
this was meant to improve Disney's
Financial results and this comes at a
time where Marvel Studios themselves are
shaking things up with the firing of
Victoria Alonso now Bob Iger has already
come out and spoken about how they are
going to be cutting back on shows and
how they want to focus on more quality
over quantity Kevin feige the president
of Marvel Studios came out and said the
same so it looks like we're getting kind
of back to how it was in phase one
through phase three a few Marvel movies
a year and then some Disney Plus shows
and of course Disney plus special
presentations thrown in there as well
but what's great is this does also free
up some money for Marvel Studios to use
Marvel entertainment was under Marvel
Studios and now the president of Marvel
entertainment Dan Buckley will remain
and he reports directly to Kevin feige
whereas before he had to report to Ike
and Kevin feige and make no mistake Ike
promoter even though he really didn't
have any say over Marvel Studios anymore
consistently tried to interfere in fact
he wanted to monitor all the activities
at the Marvel offices so at one point he
installed at least 20 cameras throughout
the offices but of course eventually
Disney ended up ripping them out then
for Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
madness he demanded financial
information about the movie and he kept
questioning Kevin feige's decision to
spend 200 million dollars to make the
sequel which ended up earning 956
million dollars worldwide and overall
from what we've heard he was kind of
just a bummer to have around because he
was pretty bitter about the decision to
make him really over nothing with Marvel
Studios in fact Bob Iger appeared on
CNBC and was asked about if a feud
perhaps fueled the shake-up that caused
Ike promoter to not be over any movies
or shows Bob Iger said this well you'd
have to ask Ike about that at but let's
put it this way it was not happy about
it and I think that unhappiness exists
today well Bob Iger promised a shake-up
over at the studio and now it is
happening of course like you said this
is to cut costs and with this firing and
the firing of Victoria Alonso hopefully
that means that Kevin feige is going to
be more involved and hopefully he has a
little bit more money to make these
projects a little bit better not only
that but Kevin feige did confirm that
they are going to release fewer Disney
plus projects per year this also opens
up more money per year for them as well
to spend on each project so overall them
cutting back on projects and Disney
cutting back on costs does give Marvel
Studios a good opportunity here to
really increase the quality of content
that it has been releasing so hopefully
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in general
is about to get better with their Disney
Plus shows and their movies and if one
thing is for certain right now it is
that Marvel Studios has heard the fans
they have heard the fans complaints and
they are actively trying to get better
there's no doubt that most fans out
there right now prefer phase one through
three over phase four a lot of fans have
said that the quality has simply lacked
all around with the CGI with the
storytelling with the characters don't
get me wrong I don't think phase 4 has
been that bad but there are a lot of
dissatisfied fans out there however
Kevin feige has mentioned this is a
building face and Phase 5 is going to
get big and phase six is going to be the
biggest Marvel Studios has ever tried to
be with the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
right around the corner at least we hope
hopefully there aren't too many delays
and hopefully we still get Avengers King
Dynasty and Secret Wars in a few years
but the best part is Marvel Studios
really is shaking things up they are
intending on getting better so a bright
future is ahead for Marvel Studios but
let us know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest MCU news you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf